June 2014.
Flying over remote Utah desert.
Eyes in the sky Capture this image.
This is crazy.
In the middle of what looks to be nowhere.
There's a very purposeful pattern.
Further images reveal yet more unusual shapes
in the desert.
Scrub below.
These patterns come in different shapes and
sizes.
There's one that looks like a big ice cube
tray.
One kind of looks like a wagon wheel.
So what possible purpose could be served by
creating these patterns on the desert in
close proximity to one another?
Analysts consider if the shapes are a legacy
of the indigenous tribes who once ruled these
lands.
This area was inhabited by tribes of the
Navajo Nation, and they use numerous symbols
in their culture.
Elsewhere, giant symbols have been found
carved into the earth.
Some are believed to have had a magical
function, possibly a form of prayer or an
attempt to communicate with gods who inhabit
the skies.
Some of these symbols were for protection,
some of them were for life giving and some
were for luck. So I'm wondering, maybe the
things we're seeing here could be Native
American symbols.
Yet studies of Utah's Indigenous people
suggest the strange patterns aren't some kind
of ancient code.
It's unlikely because they usually put their
symbols into rock faces, not on the ground.
Military journalist Carlo Munoz suspects the
patterns may have a sinister purpose and is
traveling to the remote site to investigate.
We're we're driving right now.
We're near one of the US government's most
important sort of training grounds for
chemical and biological weapons.
Munoz knows that experimental military
testing takes many forms and can leave long
lasting scars on the landscape.
There's got to be some sort of connection.
I just can't put my finger on exactly what
that could be.
One notorious Utah base could help shed some
light.
It's entirely possible that these symbols are
connected to the Dugway Proving Ground.
The operations that go on at Dugway are
really top secret.
I mean, these.
Are the types of operations that you would
put maybe on par with something going on at
Area 51.
Declassified records confirm Dugway
scientists have been conducting clandestine
bioweapons experiments in the Utah desert
for almost 80 years.
These include trialling the aerial dispersal
of gas, weaponized mosquitoes and fleas
infected with the bubonic plague.
Dugway aerial experiments here remains some
of the most controversial in US military
history.
With the high level of activity at Dugway
Proving Ground.
It's quite possible that these shapes are
related to what's going on there.
Could they be targets? Could they be some
sort of side effect?
Some of these tests, I don't know what.
We're going to go see what's happening.
The desert road stops long before the shapes
begin.
All right. This looks about as far as I'm
able to go.
Munoz approaches the location indicated by
the aerial images.
But finding them isn't easy.
You know, you look at the satellite image,
the symbol just pops out.
But here on the ground.
I mean, seeing what I'm seeing, I could be
standing right on top of it, not even know.
Okay, You know what?
I think this is it.
You've got two paths going this way.
You turn here.
You have the same exact sort of pattern.
Here. Turn again and it's there again.
So this this is probably the center of it.
From the ground. The symbol lacks the
precision visible from the air.
Whatever this is, Munoz doesn't think
military testing can explain it.
I'm not seeing any signs of military
activity.
There's no craters or whatnot.
So this is clearly not some kind of
extension of a military base.
The desert floor yields some clues.
This is all loose sand as long as I've been
walking.
But coming down here, looking down this
path.
This is packed down.
This is almost designed to take a very heavy
weight.
The shape is huge, Munoz reckons.
12,000 square feet.
The plant growth suggests it may be decades
old.
Whoever built this thing, they built it to
last.
Why would someone do that?
What makes it even weirder is we know that
there are several other symbols out here just
as big.
Munoz thinks the shapes nearby must be
connected.
That symbol may have been similar to
something like.
The X on a treasure map.
Well, the question is.
What exactly were they looking for?
Munoz turns to aerial images for help.
To the north. He spots what could be a small
abandoned mine.
If I can figure out what exactly they were
mining out of this old mine, hopefully I can
figure out what these symbols out here for.
Munoz sets out further into Utah's perilous
desert.
It was not until the late 18th century that
Europeans dared to explore these arid lands.
There it is.
Beyond the mining huts, Munoz spots an
entrance into the rock face.
Oh, wow. Oh.
So this is the mine.
What? It looks like we're a little barred
off here.
It's not going to be able to get in.
This can't be a gold mine.
The nearest known deposits of gold lie far
to the north and east of here.
If you take a look, look how far that goes
into the rock face.
I've heard of mines like this kind of carved
right into rock.
And it could be a uranium mine.